The House of the Dragon season finale
was pretty brutal but it could have been
terrifying the first season of The Game
of Thrones prequel includes several
intense birth scenes that emphasize the
brutal nature of childbirth in Westeros
indeed the very first episode features a
particularly violent and bloody scene in
which Queen Emma's labor goes horribly
wrong and neither the mother nor the
baby survives episode 6 features two
more birth scenes modern Witch Princess
rhaenyra Targaryen delivers her baby and
then immediately marches through the red
keep trailing blood and another in which
Elena valarian commits suicide by Dragon
after her own labor goes awry I reached
the limit of my art yet the series saves
us most disturbing birth scene for the
season 1 finale in which we see rhaenyra
enter labor prematurely and deliver a
deformed stillborn baby named vicenia
although the camera doesn't linger too
long on baby visenya within the episode
a recent Instagram post from the series
prosthetic makeup designer Barry Gower
gives us a closer look at the baby's
Design Within the episode itself it's
hard to get a good look at the stillborn
for senya as she is covered in blood and
held tightly in the arms of rhaenyra but
gower's post illuminates some of the
finer details with two brightly lit
images of baby vicenia against the black
background the first one highlights her
to formed nose and sunken face and the
second shows her cone-shaped skull the
most striking deformity present in these
two images is the numerous dragon-like
scales that cover vessenia's head chest
and back the second image shows that she
has an abundance of these scales on the
back of her head and running down her
spine and that the back of her head
features an almost horn-like protrusion
that accounts for a skull's shape
considering the immense amount of
details shown in this small model is
surprising that these scales are so
obscured in the episode itself
especially since they are specifically
mentioned in the series Source material
Fire and Blood In The Fire and Blood
chapter the dying of the Dragons a fool
known as mushroom claims that rhaenyra
curse baby senya during her premature
birth calling her a monster and yelling
for her to get out mushroom goes on to
allege that these curses bore fruit when
the vicenia was finally born saying when
the baby at last came forth she proved
indeed a monster a stillborn girl
twisted and malformed with a hole in her
chest where her heart should have been
and a stubby scaled tail it's worth
mentioning that mushrooms account of the
events in Fire and Blood is considered
to be a reliable and exaggerated so it
makes sense that the design team chose
to tone down his version of vicenya for
House of the Dragon while still making
her somewhat dragon-like although this
silicon model does not appear to include
the tale it's clear that the Prosthetics
team paid close attention to the details
of the senya's malformed appearance and
scales culminating in the design we see
in gower's Instagram post it's hard to
grasp the immense attention to detail
that went into this model when watching
the episode itself due to visenya's
incredibly brief appearance though
gower's post makes it abundantly clear
that the Aesthetics Department went
above and beyond to make this final
birth scene really stand out amongst all
the others in the series